and of all the different features and
new services that Apple's unveiling at
this particular WWDC which one is the
greatest importance to investors
streaming music is definitely what I
would view is the banner sort of
announcement and it's not that
financially speaking it significantly
moves the needle for Apple it shows
Apple getting more into the software
piece but we ultimately believe this
goes into a streaming TV and ultimately
a one-stop-shop type of device that
comes down 2016 so streaming music is
really them going i would say against
spotify in terms of a battle royale but
it's really them putting more of a fence
around their backyard the one theme that
i would say and talking a lot of
developers the confidence it's really
about software this is really apple
transitioning from you know hardware's
continues to be its bread-and-butter but
if you look out next to 35 years
software is the epicenter that's really
going to be the key ingredients in their
growth so I think you know you also saw
some Apple pay announcements which are
pretty important as well as on the watch
from the app development so I think
altogether I would call it so far as an
a minus b plus conference relative to
what we were expecting hey Dan did they
wind up making money off of the software
the software is the highest margin piece
they have and even though today it's all
been about hardware for Apple and that's
where they've made their brand the gold
standard of technology but Germans are
going forward as the hardware starts
become a little more commoditized both
on smartphone we've already seen the
tablet side it goes to what is the key
for Apple what separates them it's the
software and the software services piece
as we go out and to potentially
wearables beyond the watch augmented
reality Apple pay we saw a rewards
program which is key there this is all
about Tim Cook the two da dough growth
its iPhone 6 in China near-term it
really drives the Apple story but as we
look forward it's these really
next-generation areas which is being led
by software and there was a big theme
today at the conference right well as
Apple pivots to software from hardware
does that mean the stock deserves a
higher multiple it's currently trading
at
us under 16 times earnings on a Ford
earnings basis 14 times earnings and 11
times that cash when you when you factor
in the cash I really think we're going
to start to see a little more of a
rereading here an apple going higher in
terms of nitrous on that software almost
recurring piece but i think the iphone 6
in the china story is still very
underestimated by the street and that's
really going to be the headline over the
next two three quarters in terms of
upside on iphone 6 as well as in china
but we get into 2016 and this is what
really apples doing save the developer
conference remember the developers are
the blood wounds and heart of apple and
they really need to weigh out that next
generation of growth opportunities in
terms of products software wearables and
i think that's what they've started to
do today so at what point do we sort of
say this is no longer Steve Jobs Apple
but it really is Tim Cook's Apple have
we gotten there I mean I think it's a
transition iphone continue to be the
meat and potatoes and will for the
foreseeable future but the one vent
separate Apple versus basically every
other technology company they're always
looking two three four steps ahead and
as they look at today they could just
sit there and not really change anything
and just on OS updates and and some
other tangential improvements instead
that really focus on this next category
it's going to be Apple pay wearable it's
potentially streaming TV which we think
comes out later this year in 2016 and
ultimately you look at otto's you will
get some other areas that's really going
to be that that next generation of
growth opportunities which I think
they've started to lay out here in terms
of the software piece I've never seen
developer common for Apple where they've
talked more about software